when it comes to
emotional scenes like that they become
incredibly powerful for me personally
and then i watched it back afterwards
and i was like oh my god it's it's
heartbreaking
it really broke my heart when we did
lose roach in season two easy go
what was it like for you to film that
scene and what did that mean for you
especially knowing the strong connection
that they've had it's always an
incredibly emotional thing i've always
had a connection with animals ever since
i was very young my mum thought i was
going to be a vet and
i obviously have a very close bond with
my dog cal and then when you spend as
many hours as i have spent riding a
horse and training with a horse and
building that relationship you do
develop a very strong emotional bond
especially when that horse is
is has such a
a soul to it such a kind um try hard
work hard mentality and so anything when
it comes to
emotional scenes like that they become
incredibly powerful for me personally
when when you when you tap into that
side of it and you you leave the
the acting behind and you draw upon the
reality of a situation
um and imagining it be true and it
becomes an intensely emotional moment
be not afraid of her
or she is your friend
it was very emotional filming it because
the horse zeus it's a train so it can
lie down
and i the best bit of acting i've seen
in the witcher
the horse starts like whimpering
as gerald um was stroking it it was just
absolutely like hot it genuinely was
heartbreaking the noises that it was
making because they'd made these big
like slices in its stomach
so like looking at it and then hearing
the whimpering of the horse like it was
it really actually genuinely was like so
sad and then i watched it back
afterwards and i was like oh my god it's
it's heartbreaking so yeah it was really
really actually emotional because the
horse was so bloody good at acting
there were so many incredible fight
sequences in season two which one are
you most excited for the fans to see
break it down for me um ah it's
difficult i think for me my favorite
sequence was and
it's a weird way of answering this
question but in episode one of season
two
what made
that fight sequence
so wonderful for me was christopher's
performance after the fight sequence he
is we know him as this this bombastic
vivacious character and
he he plays it so wonderfully in game of
thrones as well but then we see him do
this role and it was such a powerful
shakespearean moment and he is an
extraordinary talent and that made that
that that final piece that that final
note that fight scene
made it such a a powerful moment and uh
i it was all thanks to him all thanks to
his incredible performance from nivlan
who really
loves geralt and and and it's somehow
his best friend and you know to hide
stuff from your best friend it's it's
also hard so so it was uh it was
wonderful to shoot that and
and you know to finally and and yeah and
and
to play play play the secrets he has
been hiding all the time right that
witches obtain children so they can feed
them with magic herbs
talk to me about the prosthetics and the
amount of time you're in the makeup
chair in order to get that full look
well they built a suit around me and i
had seven people around me all the time
to to make that suit work
include being everybody who's who's
fitting me and and and stuff but it's
it's 95 prosthetics and it's uh and it's
5 cgi and that is my face so did you
think it was full for me
it didn't okay
cool it looked great
yeah that's good to know that's good to
know maybe i shouldn't have said it it
was just makeup you got me there
so the fans have had to wait nearly two
years for season two of the witcher
henry i'm curious to know what was your
mindset heading into the second season
did you feel any pressure to make it
bigger and better i don't think of it as
pressure i think it was responsibility
and there's only so much control i have
um this is i can't i can't control plot
lines story lines even character
direction but what i can do is is
have as much influence as i possibly can
upon my character on the character i'm
playing with geralt i wanted to bring
as much of book geralt into the season
as the showrunner's vision would allow
and so i tried to make him come across
as more intellectual
more wise i mean he's been around for 70
plus years so he's going to have a sense
of wisdom and he's also lived an
incredibly hard life so he's going to
have after many years of self-reflection
some perspective
and i try to apply that especially with
the relationship with siri i wanted to
show that that aspect of girl that
soulfulness that understand
to say you know what i'm gonna i'm gonna
sit here and tell a story and if you
want to keep on talking after that then
you can and and i think freya did an
amazing job of playing that as well of
playing the
like huh okay well he's been through
stuff too then i get it maybe i am
comfortable sharing this and i think
freya did a wonderful job of showing the
subtleties of that
[Music]